señoras y señores este de estado y de
gobierno
estimadas delegadas y delegados cada
generación ha enfrentado sus propios
problemas y desafíos a nuestra
generación le corresponde enfrentar
problemas y desafíos especialmente
difíciles y exigentes algunos han
surgido en forma inesperada como la
pandemia de coronavirus y la recesión
económica mundial que ella ha provocado
otros ya existían pero se han
manifestado con mayor fuerza como el
cambio climático y el calentamiento
global los desafíos de nuestra
generación son la madre de todas las
batallas porque estas son batallas para
asegurar nuestra propia sobrevivencia
hace un año nadie imaginaba que un virus
invisible y microscópico
iba a provocar la peor catástrofe
sanitaria y social y económica de los
últimos 100 años
ningún país estaba preparado para
enfrentarlo y mientras no existe una
vacuna eficaz y segura tendremos que
aprender a convivir con este virus que
nos ha cambiado nuestras formas de vida
nuestra forma de trabajar de estudiar de
abastecernos de relacionarnos en
síntesis la forma de vivir nuestras
propias vidas y esto significa un
tremendo desafío pero también una gran
oportunidad como hemos enfrentado en
chile- este formidable desafío nuestra
primera prioridad y ocupación es
proteger la salud y la vida de todos
nuestros compatriotas y muy
especialmente la de nuestros adultos
mayores y grupos de riesgo por eso
pusimos en marcha el plan de protección
sanitaria que nos ha permitido triplicar
la capacidad
de nuestro sistema de salud para atender
a los enfermos cominos que nos ha
permitido realizar más de tres millones
de tests pcr lo que significa que hemos
cubierto a más del 15 por ciento de
nuestra población
pero esta tarea no se agota solo con la
protección sanitaria sin duda es
necesaria pero sabemos que no es
suficiente proteger la salud y la vida
de nuestros compatriotas especialmente
cuando están bajo cuarentena también
exige asegurar a las familias para que
cuenten con el abastecimiento de bienes
y servicios esenciales para proteger los
empleos y los ingresos de las familias
para ayudar y proteger a las pymes y
para mantener un funcionamiento de
nuestra economía que la permita volver a
ponerse en marcha los chilenos hemos
enfrentado meses muy duros y difíciles
por ello nuestro gobierno desarrolló un
plan de protección social para proteger
los ingresos y los empleos de las
familias las más vulnerables y las de
clase media que hoy día cubre y presta
ayuda y alivio a más de 14 millones de
chilenos lo que significa que casi tres
de cada cuatro chilenos
tan hoy protegidos por esta red especial
de protección social que juntos hemos
construido durante estos seis meses de
emergencia pero no basta con proteger a
nuestros compatriotas solo durante el
período de la emergencia debemos ser
capaces de levantar la vista y poder
construir un sistema de protección
permanente y para eso necesitamos
recuperar nuestra capacidad de crecer de
invertir de innovar de crear empleos
es fundamental recuperar los casi 2
millones de empleos que hemos perdido
reactivar nuestra economía poner
nuevamente en marcha nuestro país y por
ello dos semanas después del primer
contagio de coronavirus en chile pusimos
en marcha un plan de recuperación
económica que hoy día moviliza cerca del
12 por ciento de nuestro producto
interno bruto
tenemos que evitar que esta crisis de
origen sanitaria y de carácter
transitorio termine transformándose en
una crisis económica y social grave y de
naturaleza más permanente
qué podemos hacer en el mundo para
enfrentar con eficacia esta pandemia y
salir fortalecidos sólo las soluciones
colaborativas y multilaterales nos van a
permitir superar esta crisis y lograr
volver a caminar esta pandemia que no
reconoce ni respeta fronteras ni
nacionalidades ni etnias nos ha mostrado
la necesidad de fortalecer la
colaboración y la gobernanza
internacional y también ha puesto en
evidencia la enorme interdependencia de
la comunidad internacional en estos
tiempos de crisis es cuando más
necesitamos liderazgos y colaboración
entre todos los países las grandes
potencias en lugar de confrontarse
permanentemente en el terreno económico
y en el terreno sanitario debieran
liderar la lucha contra esta pandemia y
la lucha para salir de esta recesión
mundial
y no generar el gran y preocupante vacío
de liderazgo que observamos hoy en
materia sanitaria
esto incluye compartir diagnósticos y
conocimientos coordinar los cierres y
apertura de nuestras fronteras unir
nuestras fuerzas para el desarrollo y
lograr tener pronto una vacuna eficaz y
segura y poder también colaborar en
forma especial con los países más
vulnerables la guerra comercial que
hemos conocido ha significado
estancamiento del comercio y de las
inversiones internacionales ha producido
un debilitamiento del libre comercio ha
generado focos de proteccionismo y
bloqueo de la organización mundial del
comercio y para promover el libre
comercio la integración para combatir el
proteccionismo eliminar las barreras no
arancelarias para armonizar regulaciones
y reglas y para impedir y sancionar
conductas unilaterales que son
contrarias al orden internacional
necesitamos reconstruir
orden económico multilateral con
instituciones respetadas por todos y
basadas en reglas conocidas por todos
además debemos unirnos para evitar que
esta pandemia y esta recesión mundial
fortalezcan los autoritarismos los
populismos que han intentado
aprovecharse de esta crisis no podemos
sacrificar las libertades que con tanto
sacrificio hemos conquistado porque ello
significaría un enorme riesgo para la
democracia la libertad y el desarrollo
de nuestros países que aprendizaje y
oportunidades nos ha dejado esta
pandemia
muchos primero aprender a ser más
humildes porque a pesar de todos los
avances científicos y tecnológicos este
virus nos ha enseñado la vulnerabilidad
la precariedad de la vida humana y de
nuestras sociedades segundo tenemos que
aprender a escuchar más y mejor la voz
de la ciencia
de las autoridades locales y de la
sociedad civil y estar siempre
dispuestos a enmendar el rumbo cuando la
evidencia lo haga necesario tercero
hemos aprendido del valor de la familia
que ha sido para muchos el principal
sustento para enfrentar y superar las
dolorosas consecuencias que estos
tiempos de adversidad han traído
aparejadas
la pandemia de coronavirus y la recesión
económica mundial han desviado los focos
de atención desde el cambio climático y
el calentamiento global hacia los temas
sanitarios y económicos pero estas
graves amenazas siguen presentes siguen
avanzando y definitivamente nuestra
mejor opción es enfrentarlas
simultáneamente
el ser humano es sin duda la criatura
más inteligente e ingeniosa que habita
en el planeta tierra
pero es también la única criatura capaz
de destruir su propio planeta
digamos las cosas como son la amenaza
del calentamiento global es real es
inminente la ciencia ha hablado en forma
fuerte y clara la ciudadanía no se exige
como un imperativo moral un cambio de
rumbo la tecnología nos provee las
herramientas y el sentido común nos urge
a la acción la evidencia científica es
categórica la concentración de gases de
efecto invernadero y la temperatura
promedio actual del planeta son las más
altas de los últimos 800.000 años
estamos siendo afectados por inmensas e
intensas olas de calor grandes
inundaciones severos períodos de sequía
poderosos huracanes y además estamos
sufriendo graves desprendimientos y
derretimiento de los hielos en los polos
y también la contaminación de nuestros
océanos y vemos cómo se incrementa el
nivel del mar aumenta los incendios
forestales y la destrucción de los
bosques
y muchos otros fenómenos que sin duda
preocupan y lo más grave es que antes
está evolución o estos cambios tomaban
millones de años
ahora están ocurriendo en apenas algunas
décadas por eso el tiempo de los
diagnósticos se acabó llegó el tiempo de
la acción cuál es el compromiso de chile
con el cambio climático
estamos totalmente comprometidos con
esta causa una causa que ha inspirado y
movilizado a millones y millones de
ciudadanos en el mundo entero chile fue
uno de los primeros 10 países del mundo
en presentar un significativo
fortalecimiento de nuestras nds
cumpliendo los compromisos que
adquirimos en el acuerdo de parís
estamos impulsando una ley marco de
cambio climático que ya fue aprobado y
por unanimidad en el senado y que fija
la meta de carbono neutralidad para el
año 2050 o antes y también determinan
las estrategias los planes y definen los
instrumentos para avanzar y cumplir con
esta meta
hemos asumido el compromiso de
transformar alquiler antes del año 2050
en un país carbono neutral es decir con
cero emisiones netas de gases de efecto
invernadero a través de impulsar muchas
acciones entre ellas el cierre total de
las centrales a carbón que producen
energía antes del año 2040 hoy el 44 por
ciento de nuestras fuentes de energía
son limpias y renovables
y al año 2030 vamos a llegar a más del
70 por ciento de fuentes de energía
limpias y renovables
también estamos avanzando la
electromovilidad reemplazando los
combustibles fósiles de nuestro sistema
de transporte por electricidad
y otros combustibles limpios al 2040 el
100 por ciento de nuestro sistema de
transporte público urbano va a ser
eléctrico y además nuestra capital es
hoy la ciudad fuera de china con más
buses eléctricos del mundo también
estamos avanzando en la eficiencia
energética en todos los sectores y
estableciendo tarifas especiales para ir
reemplazando gradualmente la leña y
otros combustibles contaminantes por
calefacción en base a electricidad
estamos también comprometidos con la
protección de nuestros bosques nuestra
biodiversidad a través de plantar y
reforestar privilegiando siempre las
especies nativas y las soluciones
basadas en la naturaleza y para cumplir
con éxito esta misión
estamos construyendo una verdadera
alianza por la ambición climática
incorporando al estado la academia el
sector privado la sociedad civil y sobre
todo a la ciudadanía también estamos
avanzando para reemplazar la cultura de
lo desechable por la cultura de los
reciclables y para pasar de una economía
lineal a una economía circular hemos
eliminado por ejemplo las bolsas
plásticas lo que nos ha permitido evitar
que 5 mil millones de bolsas plásticas
que sólo se utiliza en algunos minutos
queden posteriormente contaminando por
siglos a nuestro planeta
este es el gran desafío de nuestra
generación tenemos que recuperar el
tiempo perdido tenemos que cambiar el
rumbo a la historia para poder evitar
una catástrofe y asegurar la
supervivencia y la calidad de la vida de
los seres humanos en el planeta tierra
quiero también compartir con ustedes
algunas reflexiones sobre nuestra región
américa latina américa latina lo ha
tenido todo para hacer una región
desarrollada territorios amplios y
generosos recursos naturales abundantes
y múltiples no hemos tenido las guerras
que casi destruye en europa en el siglo
pasado
tampoco los conflictos religiosos que
tanto daño han causado a lo largo de la
historia y sin embargo sin perjuicio de
reconocer los importantes avances que
hemos logrado en muchos campos seguimos
siendo un continente subdesarrollado un
continente que tiene casi un tercio de
su población viviendo en condiciones de
pobreza y esta pobreza va a aumentar
producto de la crisis de coronavirus
por qué
porque no hemos sido capaces de
aprovechar en plenitud los talentos y
las oportunidades de nuestros pueblos
porque no hemos logrado avanzar hacia
una verdadera integración regional y
también porque estamos atrasados en
nuestra plena incorporación al mundo de
la revolución tecnológica y digital a la
sociedad del conocimiento y de
información
sin duda estamos haciendo esfuerzos para
recuperar el tiempo perdido hace 8 años
atrás creamos la alianza del pacífico
que es un referente regional de
integración económica y social hace un
año creamos pro surf que es una
instancia un foro de coordinación y
colaboración de todos los países
democráticos de américa del sur y que ha
sido muy útil para colaborar y coordinar
la forma en que enfrentamos esta
pandemia de coronavirus sin embargo
también hemos tenido retrocesos que
amenazan la libertad los derechos
humanos la democracia el estado de
derecho y la calidad de vida por ejemplo
la dramática situación que vive
venezuela donde estos principios son
permanentemente vulnerados y que está
sufriendo la más grave crisis política
social económica y humanitaria de su
historia
estamos convencidos que la mejor
solución para superar la crisis en
venezuela es la constitución de un
gobierno de transición y que realice
elecciones libres y democráticas para
que sea el pueblo venezolano el que
pueda elegir soberanamente y con plena
libertad a sus gobernantes y los caminos
a recorrer en el futuro
por otra parte el mundo entero está
siendo amenazado por el populismo y por
olas de irresponsabilidad
qué son las que proponen siempre el
camino fácil el camino de los derechos
sin deberes el camino de los logros sin
esfuerzo el camino del progreso sin
trabajo el camino de la reivindicación
de los derechos propios sin respetar los
derechos de los demás en último término
el camino de las promesas de soluciones
fáciles a problemas difíciles la
democracia se fundamenta en la libertad
y la libertad exige responsabilidad está
libertad y responsabilidad son
especialmente necesarias en estos
tiempos de crisis que estamos viviendo
porque las crisis muchas veces se
transforman en un caldo de cultivo para
el surgimiento del populismo y de la
irresponsabilidad
en los últimos tiempos nuestra región ha
conocido estallidos sociales y también
olas de violencia y chile no ha sido una
excepción hace 30 años con la firme
voluntad y compromiso del pueblo de
chile recuperamos nuestra democracia en
forma pacífica y dimos vida a una nueva
y moderna república basada en tres
acuerdos amplios y sólidos primero un
profundo compromiso con la democracia
con el estado de derecho con la
protección de los derechos humanos y con
la paz segundo un sólido acuerdo en
torno a una economía de mercado libre
abierta y competitiva y finalmente una
firme determinación para derrotar la
pobreza y avanzar hacia una sociedad con
mayor igualdad de oportunidades con
igualdad de dignidad y con igualdad ante
la ley
los hechos muestran que estos acuerdos
fueron segundos durante estos últimos
treinta años multiplicamos por más de
cinco veces nuestro ingreso per cápita
redujimos la pobreza además del 60 a
menos del 10% lo que permitió que 8
millones de chilenos más de la mitad de
nuestra población de entonces superar la
pobreza surgió una amplia y diversa
clase media aumentó la expectativa de
vida se redujo la mortalidad infantil y
aumentó la cobertura y calidad del
acceso a la salud ya la educación en
todos sus niveles
por ejemplo en educación pasamos de 230
mil a un millón 200 mil estudiantes en
la educación superior la mayoría de
ellos primeros en su generación de
acceder a la educación superior
estos logros son el resultado del
trabajo de muchos gobiernos de
diferentes signos políticos que se
comprometieron con los tres principios
que mencionaba anteriormente y con la
misión de derrotar la pobreza alcanzar
el desarrollo y hacerlo en democracia y
en paz sin embargo durante estos últimos
30 años no supimos aprovechar con
suficiente fuerza las capacidades del
crecimiento y del desarrollo para
reducir con más voluntad y velocidad
las desigualdades excesivas para frenar
abusos para avanzar hacia una mayor
igualdad de oportunidades para dar
servicios de mayor calidad en área es
tan importante como la educación la
previsión o la salud
y así a fines del año pasado surgieron
en chile y también en muchos otros
países de nuestra región y del mundo
importantes movimientos sociales en
chile- ciudadanos de todas las edades de
todos los sectores salieron a las calles
a demandar mejores pensiones mejor salud
mejor educación y también menores
desigualdades mejor calidad y menor
costo de los servicios públicos mayor
igualdad ante la ley y mejor control de
conductas abusivas todas estas demandas
a pesar del progreso anterior se venían
acumulando desde hacía muchas becas
el gobierno escuchó con atención con
sensibilidad y con un sentido de
urgencia estas demandas y puso
rápidamente en marcha una nueva agenda
social para hacerse cargo y avanzar
en la solución a estas demandas
lamentablemente y aprovechándose de
estas manifestaciones grupos
minoritarios provocaron en nuestro país
una enorme
explosión de violencia con incendios
disturbios destrucción y delincuencia
que no respetaron a nada ni a nadie y
que causaron un grave daño al cuerpo y
alma de chile en democracia no podemos
tolerar ninguna forma de violencia de
cualquier naturaleza física oa través de
redes sociales la violencia y las
amenazas y la intolerancia son
incompatibles con una sociedad
democrática que quiere vivir en paz y
que debe fundarse siempre en el respeto
el diálogo y la solución pacífica de las
controversias
durante estos meses difíciles y
violentos mientras ejercíamos nuestro
deber de restaurar el orden público y
resguardar la seguridad ciudadana para
lo cual recurrimos a estado de excepción
que están contemplados en nuestra
constitución nuestro gobierno tomó todas
las medidas y todas las precauciones
posibles y necesarias para garantizar el
respeto de los derechos humanos de todos
nuestros compatriotas aplicamos normas
estrictas para regular el uso de la
fuerza por parte de las policías en
plena concordancia con las normas
internacionales en materia de derechos
humanos adoptamos una política de plena
transparencia frente a la ciudadanía en
materia de información relacionada con
derechos humanos reforzamos el sistema
de defensores públicos concebimos a
nuestro instituto nacional de derechos
humanos ya nuestra defensoría de la
niñez apoyo logístico y acceso pleno a
todas las instalaciones policiales
hospitalarias penitenciarias y todas las
que fueron solicitadas
para poder apoyar y facilitar su
importante tarea de protección de los
derechos humanos que lo hacen en forma
autónoma invitamos al alto comisionado
de las naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos ya la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos que vinieran a nuestro
país para observar en el terreno lo que
estaba ocurriendo y toda evidencia de
abusos o uso excesivo de la fuerza
fueron puestos a disposición de la
fiscalía la cual por mandato
constitucional tiene el deber de
investigar estos hechos y cuando
corresponda llevarlos a los tribunales
de justicia para que éstos juzguen y
sancionen de acuerdo a la ley eso es lo
que corresponde es una democracia y en
un estado de derecho y vamos a hacer
todos los esfuerzos para que en chile no
haya impunidad ni para los que vulneran
los derechos humanos ni para los
violentistas que atentan contra nuestra
sociedad en estos tiempos difíciles
cuando nuestra democracia se vio
amenazada nuestro gobierno propuso
y chile optó por una salida
institucional pacífica al conflicto a
través de una reforma constitucional que
dio origen a un proceso que se iniciará
este 25 de octubre con un plebiscito
ciudadano estoy convencido que la
inmensa mayoría de los chilenos queremos
perfeccionar modernizar o cambiar
nuestra constitución en el plebiscito
del 25 de octubre los ciudadanos
democráticamente elegiremos el camino a
seguir esta crisis representa una
oportunidad para lograr un acuerdo
constitucional que permita que nuestra
constitución se hace gran marco de
unidad de estabilidad y de proyección
hacia el futuro y es también una
oportunidad para conectarnos mejor con
nuestros ciudadanos y seguir avanzando
con mayor fuerza y con mayor urgencia
hacia una sociedad más libre más
con mayor igualdad de oportunidades
donde todos seamos iguales en dignidad e
iguales ante la ley y donde el progreso
y el desarrollo sean más inclusivos y
más sustentables tenemos que aprender de
las lecciones del pasado que nos han
enseñado el valor de la unidad del
diálogo de la colaboración y de los
acuerdos después de todo una casa
dividida no puede prevalecer y también
tenemos que actuar con un sentido de
urgencia porque no tenemos tiempo que
perder y porque estamos absolutamente
convencidos que no habrá justicia social
sin crecimiento y desarrollo ni habrá
crecimiento y desarrollo sin justicia
social
tienes un país orgulloso de su historia
de sus tradiciones de su identidad y con
una fuerte vocación de colaboración e
integración internacional un país donde
siempre nos preguntamos cómo podemos
contribuir junto a todo el resto de las
naciones del mundo para que esta tierra
sea un hogar con mayor libertad paz
prosperidad justicia y con mayor
protección y armonía con el medio
ambiente por estas razones chile
contribuye a la comunidad internacional
de múltiples maneras por ejemplo
cuidando y protegiendo la antártica que
es la mayor reserva de agua dulce del
mundo y que cumple un rol insustituible
fundamental para poder combatir el
cambio climático y poder mitigar el
calentamiento global y de esta forma
reducir atenuar el derretimiento de los
hielos especialmente
nuestra and táctica es además un
verdadero laboratorio para la ciencia en
el cual participan muchos países en
todos los continentes del mundo segundo
chile está contribuyendo al desarrollo
de la astronomía la combinación única de
cumbres de montañas altas de baja
humedad atmosférica de cielos despejados
ha significado que casi el 70% de la
capacidad de observación astronómica del
mundo esté hoy emplazada en chile
tercero creando áreas marinas protegidas
con orgullo y esfuerzo más del 42 por
ciento del mar de chile cuenta hoy día
con protección ambiental y cerca de un
21 por ciento de nuestras áreas
terrestres está protegida a través de
parques reservas o monumentos nacionales
cuarto desarrollando las energías del
futuro chile fue pobre en los
combustibles fósiles y contaminantes del
pasado pero somos inmensamente ricos en
las energías limpias y renovables del
futuro la alta radiación solar de
nuestros desiertos les otorga un
gigantesco potencial de generación de
energía solar la intensidad y
regularidad de los vientos
permiten una alta capacidad de
generación de energía eólica además
estamos avanzando las energías del
mañana desarrollando hidrógeno verde que
va a beneficiar a la humanidad entera
por ser un combustible que no genera
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
la abundancia del cobre y el litio en
nuestro país nos otorgan un gran
potencial en todo lo que se refiere a la
electromovilidad
y 5o conectando américa del sur con
oceanía y asia a través del cable de
fibra óptica transpacífico lo que va a
promover una mayor integración en
nuestra región y con el mundo del
asia-pacífico facilitando y promoviendo
la innovación y la sociedad digital y
finalmente produciendo alimentos sanos y
seguros que hoy día abastecen con
múltiples productos las mesas en el
mundo entero chile y el mundo hemos
vivido los veces más duros y difíciles
de la historia reciente y estoy seguro
que los chilenos demostraremos una vez
más el alma noble y solidaria de nuestro
país y la resiliencia y temple de su
pueblo juntos seguiremos construyendo un
buen país para nacer crecer estudiar
trabajar formar familias y envejecer un
hogar común la casa de todos los
chilenos donde podemos pensar diferentes
pero tenemos que respetar esas
diferencias y estar dispuesto a dialogar
colaborar y llegar a acuerdos para
construir un país y un futuro mejor que
podamos llegar con orgullo y con
esperanza a las generaciones que vendrán
muy buenos días y muchas gracias